last question today hey David if you
were single would you be on tinder
probably yeah I mean I don't know I know
that there are other websites now like
bumble and coffee meets bagel and
there's people who are friends I know
are going back to match.com which is a
pay service even though I understand
that it's much fewer people it seems
that this is how a lot of relationships
are starting these days so I don't know
why wouldn't I be on tinder if I were
single yeah our Christian mingle or JK
they're gay baby
I actually so JDate when I worked at
Circuit City I'm black people me to get
on or Christian mingle Zach Chris me
being on I would I have no preference
when it comes to race in terms of women
but I can't see myself dating a
Christian so like if you if you say to
me
would you would you prefer to find
people to date on black people meet
versus Christian mingle I've on black
people meet every day I mean there's
just no question about it I'm just
imagining your profile on those websites
be pretty funny I think it'd be fine
when I worked at Circuit City some I was
the only Jewish employee in the store
and I'd have like 90 employees or
something so some of my co-workers
thought it was funny to make a profile
for me on JDate and at the time I had
just I think I just graduated from high
school it was like the summer between
high school and college and I ran into
someone from my high school who was
going to be a senior so I was like 1
year older and she said hey I saw you on
JDate I said what what are you talking
about right now and she said yeah I saw
yeah it's no big deal like she's Korean
she said I'm Korean but I'm also on
JDate just cuz you know I like Jewish
guys and whatever and I had no clue what
on earth was going on and ultimately it
turned out that some of my co-workers at
Circuit City had made a profile for me
which of course I didn't even have
access to the girl that pointed that out
to you do you think she was trying to
open up an opportunity for us was she
interested in you do you think it's
possible and I would never know if she
had contacted me because I didn't even
have access to the account yeah I guess
the only thing I would be a little bit
more concerned about is long-term
relationships because the question
always comes back to how did you meet
and I don't know if it's because of our
traditions here but it seems like I
don't know you
to be able to say that you met somewhere
spontaneously or whatever people just
don't care anymore I don't care I know
people who are I have a friend who is
married with two kids and she met her
husband on tinder and it seems like the
stigma around it has been very very
reduced maybe there's parts of the
country where it's different but in
cities half the people I know who are in
relationships just say we met online and
then the follow-up question is oh that
sounds great
which service did you use because I'm
not having luck or whatever I think that
the stigma in coastal elite cities has
basically evaporated uh all right if I'm
wrong let me know but I am NOT on tinder
because I am not single swipe right if
you liked this video maybe yes I like
that or just like and comment or like
comment and subscribe we will talk to
you on the bonus show WWE at medCom to
sign up you can also access the bonus
show by becoming a patron at patreon.com
slash david pakman show